Transcriber: somaya hedya
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
أهلًا بكم.
تقول الأسطورة أن لدى كل أطفال متلازمة داون
نفس الشكل والقدرات وإطار النمو.
وليس الأمر مقتصرًا على ذلك فقط،
يعتقد العديد منّا أيضًا أن الأطفال عامةً
يُفترض أن يكبروا ويترعرعوا
ويتعلموا بنفس الطريقة.
في الحقيقة، كان هذا أيضًا
هو تفكيري من 11 سنة،
ومن أجل تغيير هذه الفكرة،
مررتُ برحلة طويلة
بين الإنكار والرفض والقبول.
بدأت الحكاية..
من ابني..
حيث كان لدي حلم أن أنجب طفلًا
وأسميه عليًا، وفعلًا جاء علي إلى الدنيا.
لكن يومًا بعد يوم وشهرًا بعد شهر،
يكبر علي لكن بشكل مختلف قليلًا.
ريما تكون عيناه ضيقتان وشعره ناعم.
طفل هادىء قليلًا، لكنه في حالة جيدة،
فلا يوجد أم لا تريد أن يكون طفلها
هادئًا ولطيفًا وجميلًا.
لكن كان يقول لي قلبي
أن هناك شيء مختلف عند علي.
ولأجل ذلك، ذهبنا إلى طبيب واثنين وثلاثة،
لغاية ما وصلنا إلى الطبيب الرابع،
وأخبرنا أن لدى ابننا متلازمة داون.
طبعًا، قلت مَن هذا الطبيب
الذي لا يفهم شيئًا.
نرى هذه الأمور في الشارع وفي التلفاز،
ونقرأ عنها عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.
لكن أن تحدث لنا، بالتأكيد لا.
وأيضًا أنا ووالده لسنا أقارب،
ولا يوجد شيء مثل هذا في عوائلنا، فأكيد لا.
لكن قلنا لا بأس، وللاطمئنان
علينا الذهاب وعمل التحاليل،
وفعلًا عملنا التحليل مرة واثنتين.
وأكيد أنتم تتخيلون
ماذا كانت نتيجة التحليل!
بالضبط، تم تشخيص علي
بمتلازمة داون وعمره 9 شهور،
لحظة توقف عندها الزمن،
وأصبح كل شيء سوداويًا،
وتحول الحلم إلى كابوس.
والبنت التي كانت تحلم
في أن تنجب طفلًا لتلعب معه،
أصبحت مسؤولة عن طفل مختلف
في وسط مجتمع لا يتقبل معظمة الاختلاف.
ولأول مرة في حياتي،
أضطر إلى كسر الصور النمطية،
وأتوقف عن الحكم على الناس من الخارج.
لأن الأمر قد انتهى،
أصبح لدى ابني تشخيص واضح عليه،
فأكيد  لا أريد أن أؤذيه،
ولا أريد من الناس أن تؤذيه أيضًا.
لا أنكر أنني كنت خائفة في ذلك الوقت،
كنتُ خائفة حيث كنت لا أعرف شيئًا عن المرض.
ولأن الإنسان عدو ما يجهل،
قررت أن أقرأ وأتعلّم أكثر عن متلازمة داون.
والحقيقة أنني عرفت معلومات كثيرة جدًا؛
عرفت أن الاسم الصحيح هو متلازمة داون،
أو ثلاثية الكروموسوم 21  (Trisomy 21)،
أو داون سيندروم ولا يطلق عليه
اسم الطفل المنغولي.
عرفت أن كلمة داون معناها أصلًا مرتبط
باسم الطبيب الذي اكتشف التشخيص،
وليس معناها أنه هو داون
أو أنه أقل من أي أحد.
عرفت أيضًا أنه أي نعم هو خلل جيني،
لكن ليس بالضرورة أبدًا أن يكون وراثيًا،
وليس بالضرورة أن  أكون أو والده السبب.
وأن 95%  من الحالات
تكون بسبب طفرة جينية وليس بسبب وراثي.
وعرفتُ أيضًا أن أطفال متلازمة داون
يقدرون أن يتكلموا ويتعلموا
ويدخلوا مدارس وجامعات ويشتغلوا
لو توفرت لهم خدمة تدخل مبكرة جيدة.
وليس بالضرورة أبدًا أن يكون لدى
طفل متلازمة داون قصور ذهني.
ما كان مؤسفًا بالنسبة لي أنني وجدت
المتخصيين في المجال الطبي أو التعليمي
أو التأهيلي لديهم معلومات قديمة
أو مغلوطة عن متلازمة داون.
على سبيل المثال هذا الكتاب،
هذا كتاب يُدرس في جامعة عندنا هنا،
هل ترون ما هو عنوان الكتاب؟
بالضبط، التخلف العقلي!
هذا هو مستوى العلم الذي يُقدم،
وما زلنا بعيدين جدًا في هذا الجزء.
ليس الأمر مقتصرًا على ذلك، فقد اكتشفتُ
أن الأماكن المخصصة لاستقبال الأطفال
في كثير منها ترفض أصلًا استقبال أطفال
مختلفين مثل: المدارس والحضانات.
ومثلًا لن نجد ممرات مسطّحة
في الأماكن العامة تسمح للأطفال
الذين يستخدمون كراسي متحركة
أن يتحركوا بحرية وكأن ليس لهم وجود.
ومثلا لن نجد هناك أماكن لألعاب الأطفال،
أو أماكن مخصصة متوفرة للأطفال
تسمح للأطفال ذوي الكراسي المتحركة
أو الذين لديهم مشاكل سمعية
أو بصرية أو حسية أن يظلوا داخلها.
ويوجد كثيرًا من هذا القبيل.
بعد أن تأكدنا من تشخيص علي،
بدأنا مرحلة التدخل المبكر
مع أطباء ومتخصصين.
لكن هذا وحده لم يكن كافيًا بالنسبة لي.
فقررتُ أن أنظر وأبحث لماذا
يتطور بعض الأطفال أفضل من غيرهم،
لماذا يقدر بعض الأطفال
على عمل أشياء ويعجز عنها آخرون؟
ما الفارق؟
الفارق بالتأكيد ليس فقط
في المكان الذي يُولد فيه الأطفال.
بالتأكيد الفارق في العلم والخدمة المُقدمة.
ولذلك ذهبت ودرست أكثر عن التدخل المبكر،
وسافرت لأكثر من مكان لأتعلم أكثر
عن التطور الدماغي والتنوع العصبي،
وكيف نساعد الأطفال المختلفين الذين  لديهم
مشاكل جينية أو تنموية لتكون قدراتهم أفضل.
وجدتُ نفسي لا أساعد علي فقط،
وجدت نفسي أساعد علي،
وأطفال آخرين وأمهات أيضًا.
حتى لا يشعر أحد فيهم
أنه بمفرده كما كنت أشعرُ سابقًا.
ومن هنا جاءت فكرة بوند (Bond)؛
بوند هو مجتمع يضم آباء
وأمهات لديهم أطفال مختلفون،
وهدفنا فيه أن نتشارك:
نشارك الخبرات والتجارب و المشاعر والأفكار
حتى لا يشعر أحد منّا أنه بمفرده.
ولكي يساعد من سار هذا الطريق
من قبلُ غيره لكي يُكمل.
والآن أكملنا ثلاث سنوات مع الأمهات،
نقدّم خدمات مختلفة:
نقدم خدمات الدعم النفسي،
والدعم الأسري وورش عمل
عن التدخل المبكر والدمج التعليمي.
ونعلم الأمهات كل ما يخصُ أولادنا.
ليس علي هو بطل الحكاية بمفرده،
فليليا أخت علي الصغيرة
جزءٌ كبير من حكايتنا.
ليليا طفلة لديها قدر كبير
من التقبل والتسامح لأي شخص مختلف عنها،
أيًا ما كان شكله أو دينه
أو لونه أو جنسه أو حتى قدراته،
لأنها تربت في بيتٍ فيه طفل مختلف،
فصارت ترى أن هذا شيء عادي،
وأنه بالفعل مختلف عنها،
لكنه ليس أقل منها في شيء.
إنه مختلف عنك، لكنه ليس أقل مِنك.
هذا هو علي،
يستطيع علي القيام بكثير من الأشياء:
يدرس علي في مدرسة عادية، في الصف الرابع.
وهو يتكلم ويتعلم ويقرأ ويكتب
ويفعل كل شيء مثله مثل باقي الأطفال.
ليس هذا فقط، يلعب علي أيضًا على آلة الطبل،
وسيقدم الشهر القادم
الأداء الثالث له على المسرح.
كما يحلم علي أيضًا بأن يكون طباخًا.
في كثير من الأوقات، يكون المجتمع
هو المُعيق بسبب رفضه للاختلاف.
رفض المجتمع للاختلاف يجعل الأم
تشعر وكأنها وابنها قادمان من كوكب آخر.
وأنها لابد أن تأخذ ابنها
وتذهب بعيدًا حتى لا يرفضها أحد.
مع أننا لو أدركنا أن الاختلاف سنة الحياة،
وأنه رحمةٌ من ربنا على الأرض،
وأن ربنا قد خلقنا مختلفين لنتعلم ونتشارك.
ستكون حياتنا بالتأكيد أفضل وأسهل بكثير.
لماذا أقول هذا الكلام اليوم؟
أقول هذا الكلام اليوم لأنكم مستقبل ابني.
أنتم المجتمع الذي سيعيش فيه.
وإذا كان هذا المجتمع دامجًا
ومتقبلًا للاختلاف،
فبالتأكيد، ستكون حياته
وحياة أطفال كثيرين مثله أفضل وأسهل بكثير.
الدمج حق يكفله القانون المصري،
لكن ما ينقصنا حقيقةً
أن يكون المجتمع دامج ومتقبل للاختلاف.
إنني أشجعكم لكي تقرأوا وتعرفوا أكثر
عن الفروقات الفردية بين الأطفال،
وعن الاختلافات والإعاقات عامةً.
وتقرأوا وتعرفوا أكثر عن الإتكيت
أو آداب التعامل مع ذوي الإعاقة
فهذا شيء فارق جدًا في نفسية الأم والطفل.
آخر ما أود قوله،
هو أننا جميعًا مختلفون
عن بعضنا بشكل أو بآخر،
وكلنا نحتاج لأن يقبلنا الناس رغم اختلافنا.
كل طفل له حكاية مختلفة.
اسمعوا قصص الأطفال،
ولا تسيروا وراء الأسطورة.
شكرًا لكم.
(تصفيق)